depuis plus de 10 ans à savonnière dès
que Noël approche et que la nuit tombe
une habitation ne passe plus inaperçue
avec ses 60 Père Noël et ses dizaines de
mètres de guirlande le jardin situé en
route du pied fleuy attire les passants
celui qui est à l'origine de cette
animation et notre invité du jour Mathis
cyclé bonjour bonsoir vous êtes donc
passionné de décoration de Noël alors on
va le voir l'année dernière notre caméra
avait investi le jardin de vos
grands-parents on va donc regarder à
quoi ça ressemblait l'année dernière
expliquez-nous depuis quand est-ce que
vous décorez comme ça le jardin de vos
grands-parents alors j'ai commencé à
l'âge de mes 6 ans donc ça fait plus
d'une dizaine d'années maintenant j'ai
commencé avec une simple guirlande et
donc aujourd'hui d'année en année le la
passion a grandi et ça donne le résultat
qu'on peut voir ce soir qu'est-ce qu'il
y a en stock là vous il y a des quantité
des quantités de guirlande il quo il y a
plus de 200 prises oui environ 4 à km et
demi de guirlande et donc des centaines
de sujets différents et des nouveautés
que je crée donc tous les ans quel est
le budget que vous consacrez à à cette à
ces décorations euh chaque année je
consacre à peu près entre 500 et 600 €
de mon budget pour cette passion ouais
et cette année je crois qu'il y a de
nouveautés vous rajoutez des petites
choses chaque année oui tous les ans il
y a des petites nouveautés et donc là
cette année il y a en l'occurrence une
locomotive que j'ai fait que avec des
matériaux de recyclage donc un bidon des
des planches de bois et cetera et une
église également que j'ai pu souder
moi-même j'essaie de créer le maximum de
choses par mes propres moyens et on va
le voir évidemment ça fait le bonheur
des riverins et des familles du secteur
qui viennent vous vous visiter le jardin
de vos grands-parents c'est ce qu'elle
nous expliquait déjà l'année dernière
écoutez-les tous les ans avec les
enfants on vient on se déplace jusqu'ici
pour la ferriie de Noël c'est vra que
c'est magnifique des fois on voit ça en
effet en reportage à la télévision mais
là aussi près de chez moi non j'enai
jamais vu une aussi bien décorée et puis
enchanteur on redevient vraiment une
petite fille quoi ça donne envie de
retourner au pays des Noël de notre
enfance donc chaque année il y a aussi
une difficulté je crois c'est de poser
l'étoil en haut du sapin parce que le
sapin il a grandi en même temps que vous
oui oui le sapin effectivement c'est le
mon premier Noël donc ma famille mes
parents ont planté ce sapin donc à l'âge
de mes 1 an et donc maintenant il a 20
ans donc ça devient de plus en plus
compliqué à pouvoir atteindre le sommet
pour placer l'étoile il fait combien de
haut le sapin maintenant il fait entre
10 et 11 m maintenant ouais on le voit
il y a aussi une petite cabane voilà
vous vous construisez beaucoup de choses
par vous-même on va le préciser vous
êtes paysagiste donc déjà l'univers du
jardin c'est quelque chose que vous
connaissez que vous maîtrisez mais vous
aimez bien faire par vous-même aussi oui
j'aime bien bah j'adore le bricolage et
donc mon métier qui est également un
métier de passion euh me m'oblige à être
assez bricoleur et donc pouvoir créer le
maximum de choses par ses propres moyens
c'est ce qui fait également la
différence des choses qu'on ne voit pas
qu'on peut acheter dans le commerce
alors les décorations elles vont
commencer dès demain samedi à partir de
17h30 comment ça se passe vous laissez
tous les gens rentrer dans le jardin euh
donc tous les soirs oui je serai présent
de 17h30 à 20h donc au un route du
piedfleuy sa et voilà savonnière et je
j'accueillerai les gens pour voir la
visite parce que de la route on ne peut
pas tout observer il y a une cabane avec
une crèche que l'on peut pas
voir de laavirie donc voilà et je crois
que vous êtes plein d'attention pour les
gens qui viennent voir il y a des petits
chocolats il y a des chocolats oui il y
a du vin chaud pour les gens qui veulent
et donc moi mon plaisir c'est de faire
plaisir aux autres vous avez pas encore
la taille pour être papa Noël alors vous
vous dites bon vous êtes un lutin de
Noël c'est ça bon et ben en tout cas
j'espère que votre passion a réussi à la
transmettre aux spectateurs aux
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent le
jardin est donc ouvert à partir de ce
samedi
17h30 vous l'avez dit ça se passe à
savonnière au un route du pied fleuie
merci beaucoup Mathis et bonne fête de
fin d'année merci
merci